Hallo und herzlich willkommen zu Raumzeit dem Podcast über Raumfahrt und andere kosmische Angelegenheiten mein name ist und ich begrüße alle hierzu ausgabe nummer siebenundsiebzig von raum zeit
die mich heute mal wieder in die weite welt geführt hat nicht ganz so weit aber außerhalb von Berlin nehme ich das ganze auf nämlich
bin ich heute gefahren nach
Böblingen genau genommen sitze ich im rathaus warum das werde ich gleich noch erläutern und zunächst einmal begrüße ich aber mein gesprächspartner nämlich stefan hallo schönen guten tag.
Schönen guten tag herr riedler.
Ja heute wollen wir sprechen über pflanzen.
Und pflanzen hat man ja vielleicht nicht so als erstes im kopf wenn's ums all geht und die raumfahrt tatsächlich ist es aber ein thema eigentlich sogar auch ein großes thema
ähm bevor wir darauf allerdings kommen möchte ich wie immer erstmal ein bisschen den blick zurück in ihre persönliche geschichte wagen.
Die wenn ich das richtig sehe mit
ja ein studium von luft- und raumfahrttechnik vielleicht nicht angefangen hat aber zumindest dann mal stark in die richtige richtung marschiert ist vielleicht noch ein bisschen weiter zurück gespielt war das schon immer so der kindheitstraum so.
Raumfahrt.
Also es gehörte immer zu den äh zu den großen träumen was passiert eigentlich dort oben am himmel ob es dann mal später astronomie werden sollte oder tatsächlich luft- und raumfahrttechnik das wusste ich als kind noch nicht.
Ähm nach dem abitur habe ich mich dann gezielt richtung luft- und raumfahrttechnik interessiert auslöser war tatsächlich der film apollo dreizehn.
Nicht mehr sind nicht mehr die generation wo man jetzt die mondlandung zitierte hatte ich ja auch schon diverse alte hasen die.
Nein die mondlandung ist vor meinem geburt schon entstanden und deswegen war es da tatsächlich dann nochmal der film aspekt und auch diese ganze technik die dahinter steckt um den menschen ins weltraum zu in den weltraum zu bringen und vor allem auch wieder sicher,
zu bringen das hat mich fasziniert und daher war mein studium der luft- und raumfahrttechnik von vornherein zu angelegt das mein schwerpunkt immer irgendwo auf der raumfahrt liegt.
Der film ist von fünfundneunzig.
Passt gut neunundneunzig hab ich mein abi gemacht.
Genau sind ja baujahr achtzig also noch eigentlich ganz frisch dabei
okay dann also hier in also hier nicht aber hier um die ecke in stuttgart gibt's eine entsprechende gereicht so viele luft- und raumfahrt ausbildung standort es gibt glaube ich noch braunschweig.
Ja in aachen kann man auch luft- und raumfahrttechnik als vertiefung studieren tatsächlich noch an der bundeswehr universität in münchen,
und die einzigartigkeit war in stuttgart immer dass man luft- und raumfahrttechnik vom ersten semester an studieren konnte.
Das war mir auch persönlich dann sehr wichtig weil man von beginn an mit bestimmten charakteristika aus der luft- und raumfahrt konfrontiert wurde.
Das hat mir sehr viel spaß gemacht und
als es damals im diplom studiengang so langsam richtung hauptstadtstudio um ging also raus aus dem vor studium vor diplom dann ins haupt studium und man hat seine vertiefung fächer gewählt da gab es für mich da nur noch.
Raumfahrt fächer und auch die entsprechenden theoretischen fächer wie thermodynamik äh oder auch strömung s mechanik.
Klingt ja eigentlich nach äh einer karriere als raketen ingenieur.
Ja fast tatsächlich haben mich aber auch immer so systemische betrachtung sehr interessiert also wieso gesamt systeme eigentlich funktionieren und so kam es dann dass ich nach dem studium sich zweitausend.
Abgeschlossen hab als pro moment angefangen habe meine promotion gestartet hab.
Professor messerschmidt ja auch kein unbekannter in der bemannten raumfahrt deutscher astronaut.
Und dort habe ich mich dann mit lebenshaltung systemen angefangen zu beschäftigen lebenshaltung systeme
was für technische voraussetzungen was für technologien brauchen wir um den menschen am leben zu erhalten in so einer herrschen umgebung wie dem weltraum und angefangen von ganz einfachen umgebung parametern wie temperatur.
Luftfeuchtigkeit bis hin zu weichen faktoren welche welches licht braucht man wie schafft man orientierung
wie schafft man stress zu reduzieren
und aber auch wie schafft man langzeit missionen im weltraum auch realisierbar zu machen die es ist ja nur in anführungszeichen vierhundert kilometer über dem erdboden das heißt es ist eine vergleichbar kurze strecke wenn wir über missionen zum mast nachdenken und dort äh
auch die versorgung flüge mal mit berücksichtigen dann wird es richtung maß schon mal eine ganz andere hausnummer als jetzt zu eis
und gerade die kurzfristigkeit wie man die auch erreichen kann ermöglichst andere strategien um die menschen dort am leben zu erhalten,
im gegensatz zur missionen zu mars oder auch langzeit mission auf der mond oberfläche.
Gib mir die gelegenheit auch mal wieder ein quer verweis auf eine alte folge zu machen in ausgabe einundzwanzig die schon ein bisschen her ist stelle ich grade fest von zweitausendelf aber es bestimmt noch halbwegs aktuell ging's um weltraum mediziner ich mich mit super.
Kerzen unterhalten in köln beim wdr deutsch stationiert ist und sich halt genau mit solchen fragen extrem beschäftigt da ging es also im wesentlichen um
den menschen astronauten was man sozusagen sowohl aus der raumfahrt ein forschungsergebnissen für die medizin an sich herausholen kann.
Als eben natürlich auch die spezielle medizin die denn astronauten letzten endes zu gute kommt.
Auch ein ganz wichtiger aspekt das ist.
So aber dann nahm es einen anderen lauf als humanmedizin.
Ja also ich habe meine promotion dann abgeschlossen das da ging es um die energetische einbindung von brennstoffzelle in lebenshaltung systeme und auch immer die betrachtung wie kann man zukünftige lebenshaltung systeme mit biologischen komponenten hier miteinbeziehen
wir haben uns dann in stuttgart auf mikro alpen fokussiert also noch nicht gleich auf höhere pflanzen also salat erdbeeren oder kartoffeln.
Das ist ein mikro algen.
Mikro algen sind kleine grüne oder blaue einzeller.
Dem auch fotosynthese betreiben also das haben sie gemeinsam mit den pflanzen dass sie für ein foto synthetisch aktiv sind und äh durchaus kann man biomasse als eine biomasse aus mikro algen auch essen
man dient man kann also diese biomasse auch durchaus als nahrung verwenden für den astronauten
allerdings sind sie wesentlich einfacher händelbar das heißt die umgebung in denen man solche mikro algen dann kultiviert ist wesentlich wesentlich einfacher zu bewerkstelligen als jetzt eine umgebung für pflanzen
und das haben wir während einer promotion zeit studiert wir haben einen foto bio reaktor in dem mikro algen kultiviert werden aufgebaut und ja das habe ich dann während meiner promotion gemacht und danach auch noch ähm weiter als äh.
Abteilungsleiter und auch als projektleiter am institut für raumfahrt systeme gearbeitet.
Die ein weltraum projekt ein weltraum experiment initiiert für die internationale raumstation.
Um eben foto bio reaktoren weiterzuentwickeln dass die auch wirklich eine interessante technische einen interessanten technischen aspekt bieten
für zukünftige lebenshaltung systeme da sind noch sehr viele studien und forschungsfrage.
Notwendig bis man mal soweit ist dass man sagen kann ja wohl ein foto bio reaktor ist ein richtiges mittel um zwei aus der atemluft des astronauten zu reduzieren und nahrung aufzubauen und sauerstoff zu erzeugen das sind noch viele schritte hin zu
unternehmen und wir leisten einen baustein davon.
Ja klingt eigentlich nach einer steilvorlage für eine.
Lange karriere in der forschung trotzdem sitzen wir jetzt hier im im rathaus das soll nicht ganz unerwähnt bleiben im büro des oberbürgermeisters da sind sie nämlich jetzt geworden wie kann das sein.
Ja das ist richtig also am ersten april zwotausendachtzehn habe ich äh das amt des oberbürgermeisters aufgenommen und.
Ich sag mal worum geht's mir im kern es geht nur um im kern immer um den dienst am menschen.
Lebenshaltung systeme forschung macht auch dienstag menschen im licht dienst am astronauten um den astronauten am leben zu erhalten und als oberbürgermeister leiste ich ebenfalls dienst am menschen.
Natürlich in einem politischen kontext und nicht in einem technischen kontext wieder vor ich habe zweitausendelf angefangen blut zu lecken in der kommunalpolitik habt es als hobby betrieben und das hat sich immer weiter verfestigt und.
Hier im rathaus wo wir uns befinden in meiner heimatstadt böblingen hat sich dann ja zweitausendsiebzehn die gelegenheit eröffnet mich für die für die
als oberbürgermeister zu bewerben und auch zu kandidieren die wahl war erfolgreich und damit hab ich die wahl angenommen und äh jetzt ist aus meinen ursprünglichen job nämlich.
In der raumfahrt ist jetzt in mein hobby geworden und mein ursprünglicher hobby nämlich die kommunalpolitik ist jetzt mein job mal gucken was in zukunft noch so alles passiert.
Ist eigentlich aus so einer kommunalen ebene mit forschungseinrichtungen hier in der gegend dann auch noch in kontakten um da form.
Also ich halte mit meinem forschungsteam ähm dass ich am institut für raumfahrt systeme geleitet habe sehr guten kontakt,
ich bin da auch immer gut informiert was auch mit unseren experimenten
vorangeht und gleichzeitig haben wir hier in böblingen auch das hermann zentrum dort geht es vor allem um it
also auch um software technik das finde ich sehr sehr interessant weil ich bildung auch sehr sehr wichtig finde bildung ist die voraussetzung damit wir unsere gesellschaft auch gestalten können
und deshalb halte ich da wo es eben auch möglich ist dann den draht zur akademie aber tatsächlich nimmt der großteil meiner täglichen arbeit
sind es von anderen themen inzwischen dominiert.
Was ist noch keine mikro mikro algen diät hier geplant für.
Nein aber sie können ganz dort hinten in meinem dienst zimmer können sie sehen dass meine kollegen mehr einen foto bio reaktor gebastelt haben den sie mir als abschied mitgegeben haben soll von dem her werde ich jeden tag daran erinnert wo ich ursprünglich herkomme.
Super okay dann kommen wir nochmal wieder zurück zu den pflanzen.
Vielleicht mal so erstmal schauen wir vielleicht erstmal so pflanzen als forschungs- objekt meine biologie deshalb gehört ja nun wirklich zu den älteren forschungs- bereichen der menschheit.
Und es hat auch wenn ich das richtig sehe mehr oder weniger schon von anfang an auch in der raumfahrt irgendeine rolle gespielt wenn auch nicht so eine vorherrschende.
Also mit beginn der bemannten raumfahrt in den fünfziger jahren dann in den sechziger jahren.
Hat sich sehr schnell herausgestellt ja wenn wir menschen im weltraum bringen wie sieht denn dann auch das handling von pflanzen im weltraum aus und man ist sich immer auch bewusst die fotosynthese also die umwandlung von.
Kohlendioxid kohlenstoffdioxid unter der einfluss von licht.
In sauerstoff und in essbare oder auch nicht essbare biomasse das ist ein zentraler mechanismus der uns hier auf dem leben eine,
bewohnbar umgebung verschafft und.
Das ist da war schon immer der anspruch da dass man das gerne auch im weltraum bewerkstelligen möchte gerade in den siebziger jahren als dann
man sehr raumfahrt affin unterwegs war als die medien auf den raum vorzug auch intensiv aufgesprungen sind oder bereits schon ende der sechziger jahre
da war natürlich ganz früh auch schon der gedanke ja wie sieht das aus mit so einer einer permanenten raumstation im weltraum ähm wo dann auch
pflanzen wachsen können und auch vielleicht sogar tiere leben können und äh daraufhin mit dieser grund motivation und auch mit diesem mit diesem grund impuls aus der gesellschaft
mit der.
Bereitschaft aus der gesellschaft hat man bereits dann früh angefangen forschung zu betreiben funktion wie funktioniert fotosynthese im weltraum wie verhalten sich pflanzen im weltraum,
so wie wir pflanzen hier kennen sowie auch biologie pflanzen hier studiert auf der erde ist sie immer unter dem einfluss äh der schwerkraft
und auch unter dem einfluss einer reduzierten strahlung sei einfluss des weil wir letztlich auch mit unserer atmosphäre auch einen strahlenschutz haben von der sonne,
und da war dann sehr früh klar wie verhalten sich eigentlich
zellen oder auch pflanzen im weltraum teilen sie sich genauso wachsen pflanzen genauso bauen die sich genauso schnell auf wie sehen die gas umsetzungs raten ciao zwei in sauerstoff aus
und gibt es da irgendwelche änderungen wenn ja was sind die ursachen für die für die änderungen und so hat man sehr früh angefangen dann auch mit ähm pflanzen man sieht sich der modell pflanzen ausgesucht ähm
und auch mit mikro algen hat man dann angefangen diese mechanismen und die fotosynthese zu studieren und so gilt.
Spielweise auch gerade der fotosynthese mechanismus wurde mit einer mikro alge der florida eingängig untersucht und studiert.
Insofern die klorolle auch die ella mikro alge sehr früh einzug in die biologie forschung in der raumfahrt.
Also wenn ich das richtig sehe haben die russen glaube ich anfang der siebziger ja mal eins schonmal versucht so flachs samen wachsen zu lassen.
So ein bisschen hat es funktioniert aber nicht so richtig damals wusste man glaube ich auch noch nicht so viel darüber wie es denn so um die strahlung im weltall steht was was hat er sozusagen den pflanzen so als erstes ding gar aus gemacht.
Also mit was für eine umgebung müssen die pflanzen oder mit also was ist sozusagen alles anders
als auf der erde für die pflanzen.
Also wenn sie einen samen nehmen und den in die erde stecken,
dann ist es erstmal dunkel aber sie brauchen wärmen damit der samen anfängt zu keimen und sobald der samen anfängt zu keimen aufgrund des wärme einfluss des dann ähm spielt erst mal der sogenannte geo tourismus eine rolle das heißt äh.
Die wurzeln wachsen.
Gegen oder mit dem schwerkraft victor während dann dass die grüne aus keime wächst richtung.
Licht also gegen den schwerkraft rektor und sobald eben dann das kann man auch sehr sehr schön beobachten wenn man selber schon mal äh pflanzen auch ausgesät hat kann man sehr schön beobachten wie dann so langsam die erde durchbrochen wird und dann.
Spielt der lichteinfall fluss eine starke rolle das heißt
der grüne keimlinge bewegt sich richtung licht während sich weiterhin die wurzeln richtung im erdreich und nach unten ausbreiten und vor allem die nährstoffe dann aussuchen und das funktioniert so einfach eben nicht mehr im weltraum das heißt ähm
die pflanze weiß nicht wo oben und unten ist aufgrund der fehlenden schwerkraft und hier ist hat sich auch ein eigenes feld dann sehr schnell entwickelt die sogenannte gravitationswellen die diese mechanismen im einzelnen studiert.
Was löst eigentlich wo sind was löst das gefühl in anführungszeichen der pflanzen aus um zu spüren wo ist in welche richtung geht,
der schwerkraft sektoren.
Eine frage ist ist denn jetzt das licht
oder tatsächlich die gravitation entscheidend also wächst die pflanze einfach kommentarlos nach unten wenn das licht von unten kommt in unserem forschungs- aufbau oder spielt die gravitation tatsächlich auch in der pflanze eine rolle also hat die pflanze überhaupt eine eine wahrnehmung für gravitation.
Das hat sie dass die sogenannte gravity taxis und wenn die ausgestellt ist dann keimt der ähm dann keimt der samen erstmal in alle richtungen.
Aber es ist nur für die orientierung entscheidend ist es nicht für irgendeinen anderen mechanismus zwingend das gravitation vorhanden sein muss.
Das ist richtig das ist richtig und sobald sie dann aber natürlich auch eine keine ahnung haben und dann über die wurzeln auch nährstoffe und wasser aufgenommen werden
und wer da noch licht einfluss haben dann haben sie schon mal die gute voraussetzung dafür und das kann man dann sehr gut sehen dort wo eben licht herkommt sobald eben eine pflanze
spürt das licht von einer bestimmten richtung kommt dann wächst sie auch in diese richtung hin und bereitet ihre blätter dorthin aus um fotosynthese zu betreiben weil in
in der in den wurzeln oder auch im samen selber findet ja noch keine fotosynthese statt das findet erst dann mit dem mit dem aufbau von chlorophyll.
Und wenn ihr es quasi das liegt genau aus derselben richtung kommt wie die schwerkraft dann ist dann wird die schwerkraft komplett ignoriert.
Das kann ich jetzt gar nicht genau sagen was dort in solchen experimenten dann genau rauskommt weil man möchte ja im endeffekt man möchte ja studieren wie muss ein versuchsaufbau oder wie muss nachher auch ein ich sag mal eine eine eine maschine aussehen in der ich salat
kultivieren kann das heißt wie ordne ich auch meine unterschiedlichen meinen unterschiedlichen beleuchtung formen an damit die pflanze auch ordentlich wachsen kann und die große voraus äh die große herausforderung war auch immer ähm.
Im vergleich zum schwerkraft sei einfluss,
ich kann ja nicht einfach und in schwerelosigkeit in den samen in die in den boden reinstecken in die erde reinstecken das funktioniert nicht sondern wir brauchen irgendwo eine art netz wir brauchen irgendwo eine art ähm eine ein hall ein ein halte mechanismus.
Liegt auch die ganze erde einfach durch die gegend.
Genau fliegt alles durch die gegend aber wir brauchen gleichzeitig auch eine nähe erlösung das heißt wo auch dann sobald der samen keimt auch dann nährstoffe aufnehmen kann ähm in der regel anorganischen nährstoffe also stickstoff und phosphor verbindungen
diese dann auch aufzunehmen und wie kommt dieser kai
schnell und sofort an diese nähe erlösung auch heran und dort gibt es inzwischen sehr finde ich sehr finde entwicklungen die das ermöglichen dass man
den samen sehr schön fixiert in einer kleinen halterung in einem kleinen topf dort ist er fixiert und sobald die pflanze keimt.
Öffnet man öffnet man sozusagen ein mithilfe eines kleinen wieso kann man nicht wieso eingeschlossenen flaschenhals vorstellen der ist dann geöffnet und dort äh kommen dann werden dann die nährstoffe zugeführt.
Also die flüssigen über über flüssigkeiten und wichtig ist dann auch die lichter intensität entsprechend bereitzustellen sodass dann
die das pflanzen wachstum in richtung des lichtes erfolgt also es geht mehr darum auch.
Zu schauen wie müssen wie muss die umgebung aussehen dann mit eine pflanze auch äh so wachsen kann wie wir es hier auf der erde kennen.
Was waren denn so die die fehler war bei den ersten versuchen wohnt nichts funktioniert hat eben genau das diese nährstoffe so nicht erreicht werden können oder ist das licht nicht richtig war oder nicht in der richtigen menge vorhanden war.
Das sind solche das sind solche erfahrungen die man dabei gemacht hat der strahlung beeinflusst.
In der ersten generation eigentlich auch noch keine große rolle also wenn man auf der salut dort ein versucht eine
einen samen zum keimen zu bringen dann ist es noch es ist alles noch im rahmen der resilienz auch der strahlung resilienz die langzeit folgen kommen erst später zum tragen durch den strahlung beeinfluss was man falsch gemacht hat ähm.
Man war sich sicherlich auch ist auch sicherlich erstmal schritt für schritt heran gegangen man hat sehr viel erstmal.
Geguckt wie kann man versuchen um das möglichst ähnlich zu machen
wie es hier auf der erde auch stattfindet und hat sich auch erstmal damit vertraut zu machen welche umgebung braucht so einen samen dann konkret in der schwerelosigkeit
apropos polnische oder hydro polnische voraussetzungen also im prinzip wie stell ich auch die nährstoffe bereit damit äh sobald der samen keim damit er auch wirklich wachsen kann und dort hat man erstmal zu dazulernen müssen.
Was war denn so die
ersten nennenswerten experimente die jetzt in dem zusammenhang wirklich stattgefunden haben und nicht nur auf der erde.
Stattgefunden haben oder muss man überhaupt erstmal also natürlich muss man erstmal auf der erde alles vorbereitet ist ja immer so bevor man überhaupt irgendwie so ein experiment.
Hoch geschickt bekommen muss man ja viele viele seiten füllen und begründen warum das alles sinnvoll ist und warum das dann auch letzten endes nicht nur finanziell sondern auch wie auch technisch tragbar ist für so eine mission.
Wenn man ja setzen jetzt sozusagen ein experiment für die s vorbereitet das kam dann auch zum zum einsatz.
Das ist jetzt gestartet worden vor kurzem und ist jetzt gerade in der sogenannten comission phase also da halten sich jetzt gerade meine kollegen aus stuttgart am laufenden wann das experiment dann konkret in.
Okay also es geht sozusagen erst los okay was ist bisher schon gelaufen.
Also im prinzip seitdem ähm sechziger jahren hat man mit ähm mit
unterschiedlichen pflanzen hat man schon gearbeitet man hat versucht einen speziellen salat auch als es gibt einen
sehr guten also ein letztes einen sehr guten kopfsalat mit dem man sehr viele studien gemacht hat um den zum wachsen zu bringen das funktioniert auch sehr gut dann haben sowohl,
die russen eingesetzt als auch die chinesen und die europäer
und mit diesem salat möchte man erstmal grundsätzlich die machbarkeit zeigen dass man in der lage ist salat auch zu zu wachsen zu lassen haben sich übrigens auch die astronauten sehr gefreut auf der messe als man dann zum ersten mal
so salat auch ernten konnte.
Und den dann auch tatsächlich mal gegessen hat das mit dem essen sehen natürlich sehen natürlich die crew oder die ground support nicht so gerne weil man ja nicht so richtig weiß.
Passt da alles.
Bauchschmerzen klagen.
Genau also da ist spielen dann natürlich auch noch medizinische aspekte und nahrungsmittel technische
eine wichtige rolle aber da sieht man mal wie wichtig pflanzen eigentlich auch sind nämlich auch einen psychologischen dass sie nämlich auch ein bischen aspekt haben man freut sich einfach wenn man sieht wie etwas grünes wächst und gedeiht und das man kümmert sich auch darum.
Das ist eben doch was anderes als wenn ich ich sag mal eine maschine habe einen indem ein prozess hinterlegt ist um das zwei herauszufiltern dass eben permanent läuft also zwei aus der luft herauszufiltern
da läuft permanent und man muss regelmäßig ein filter wechseln oder irgendeine maintenance dran machen aber letztlich sich um eine pflanze zu kümmern ist eben nochmal etwas ganz anderes man hat ja ähm man hat,
ja sehr früh sehr früh damit angefangen und man hat mit zum beispiel auch schon experimente mit reis gemacht man hat auch mit tomaten tomaten sind ein ganz tolle modelle organismus gemacht und ähm.
Hier versucht man immer jeweils die spezifikation herauszufinden und natürlich um die voraussetzungen dass es keimen funktioniert.
Dass das wachsen funktioniert aber auch dann sogenannte sieht experimente
durchzuführen das heißt aus der pflanze entstehen ja dann wieder neue dass man die dann bestäubt und dann anschließend auch samen aus der pflanze bekommt und die dann wieder für die nächste generation
auch benutzen kann da ist man jetzt eben noch dabei sonst sieht experiment war auch tatsächlich schon erfolgreich
und arabica ist so ein modell organismus als pflanze den man gerne verwendet und mit arabien das ist.
Eine schnell wachsende pflanze also ich bin jetzt kein biologe bin ingenieur und arabien obs es haben sich die biologen ausgeguckt als hervorragenden modelle organismus
und mit dem modell organismus arbeiten arbeiten die biologen.
Um eben dann auch unterschiedliche biologische fragestellungen zu beantworten und das schöne ist immer bei pflanzen im weltraum es ist eben nicht nur eine reine.
Biologische fragestellung sondern auch immer sind es fragestellungen der technik der verfahrens technik also auch des ingenieurbüros wesens wie man dann auch die ganze wachstums möglichkeiten bewerkstelligen kann.
Und.
Gerade diese wachstums zyklen die sind eben auch sehr sehr ich sag mal limitierenden einschränken und wie lange braucht eigentlich so eine pflanze um zu wachsen wie lange brauche ich eigentlich wenn ich da drum gehe wenn es darum geht dass die pflanzen jetzt nicht nur.
Nicht nur kultivierte um sauerstoff umzuwandeln sondern eben auch um nahrungsmittel herzustellen wie lange brauche ich denn um auch das nahrungsmittel ernst ernten zu können und äh muss sich jedes mal etwa drei bis vier wochen warten bis ich dann.
Eine eine reife frucht dann in der hand habe und dann fang ich wieder von vorne an oder kommt man auch in kann man sich eine art versetzte kultivierung weise auch vorstellen damit ich permanent einen gewissen bestand an äh
früchten oder auch an nahrungsmitteln dann auch bereit gestellt bekommen haben.
Der tanja schon eine ganze ganze kaskade von unterschiedlichen pflanzen beobachtet wird das nochmal so ein bisschen auf blättern was das wort ist kleiner scherz also.
Ich denke mal zunächst einmal muss man sich ja auch generell erstmal bakterien anschauen das ist wahrscheinlich auch schon,
hat schon sehr oft stattgefunden also wie verhalten sie sich überhaupt teilen sich ordentlich verhalten sie sich in irgendeiner form genauso oder wenn viel
anders da haben wir eben eingangs ja schon die mikro alten erwähnt die letztlich auch so also als einzelner jetzt nicht sonderlich groß
sind salat kam jetzt noch und bei tomaten machen sie das sei ein modell organismus.
Was heißt das warum ist das.
Also man nimmt tomaten auch gerne einfach als modell modelle organismus für höhere pflanzen weil man damit auch sehr schön tomaten haben.
Erstmal einen guten ruf sie werden in allen kulturen gegessen und zum anderen sie haben einen guten guten mehrwert für die ernährung des menschen.
Wachsen schnell kommt auch noch mit dazu und äh damit werden auch inzwischen einige studien gemacht zum beispiel hat
im letzten jahr das experiment stattgefunden in der antarktis station neumeier drei ähm das vom wdr.
Durchgeführt wurde und initiiert wurde und dort wurde einfach mal versucht zu studieren welche verschiedenen pflanzen man auch ähm in der unter solchen isolierten bedingungen man kultivieren kann und ähm,
die.
Ja die tomate hat ja so einen sogenannten ernte index von etwa fünfundsechzig prozent das ist recht hoch das bedeutet dass ich fünfundsechzig prozent der erzeugten biomasse durch die pflanze auch tatsächlich als nahrung verwerten kann.
Also fünfundsechzig prozent der biomasse kann ich dann anschließend auch tatsächlich essen.
I s also ist ein klingt nach eis ist aber ohne eis ist also in der antarktis ist er sozusagen pflanzen anbau in der antarktis vergleichbar mit weltraum mal jetzt von der gravitation abgesehen.
Ja es ist eine lebensversicherung umgebung in der antarktis dort halten sie es keine fünf minuten in ihrem normalen outfit aus es ist kalt sie brauchen einen.
Eine geschlossene umgebung um überleben zu können darin ist man sich sehr ähnlich zu den weltraum bedingungen man ist
langzeit für eine lange zeit isoliert und kann eben
nicht mal geschwind wenn irgendetwas schiefgeht irgendwie anders eingreifen sondern man muss sich ganz gründlich im vorfeld überlegen was brauche ich.
Um meine pflanzen pflegen und wachsen lassen zu können und wie reagieren die auch dann auf die entsprechende umgebung in der sie wachsen und das.
Und es ist auch bakterielle auch wahrscheinlich ganz gut isoliert ne also ich weiß nicht wie es so mit bakterien in der antarktis so ist aber üppig dürfte das leben dort nicht sein.
Nein also es ist jetzt man achtet natürlich sehr penibel drauf dass man sauber arbeitet es ist aber keine klinisch reine umgebung das ist auch ganz wichtig auch die ist keine klinisch reine umgebung
und da gehen wir dann wiederum dass meine erfahrung am is gerade auch im immer im diskurs mit den biologen während biologen immer
gerne sogenannte akzente bedingungen haben möchten also wirklich
pure und reine bedingungen in denen sie ihre organismus studieren sagen wir von der ingenieur seite her wir brauchen ein system das funktioniert und das system das funktioniert ist häufig auch ein system das in seiner ähm.
Umgebung wächst und gedeiht äh wo es auch andere mitspieler gibt.
Und wir müssen aber schauen dass wir die parameter optimieren in denen dann der gewünschte organismus am besten weg.
Das ist dann die aufgabe des biologen an das wiederum so umzusetzen dass dann zu schaffen die parameter heraus herauszufiltern wenn sie eine tomate versuchen lassen wollen bei minus zehn grad zu wachsen zu lassen dann wird es nicht funktionieren,
hingegen wenn sie schauen dass immer wohl temperiert bei zwanzig grad fünfundzwanzig grad sind da haben sie da sehr gut.
Kurze zwischen einleitung also wenn wir es äh mein mein institut für.
Systeme angesiedelt hat an der uni stuttgart was wir eingangs erwähnt hatten ich finde jetzt diesen gedanken ganz gut dass man.
Pflanzen erstmal versuchen sehr isoliert zu betrachten sei es jetzt halt im all oder eben.
In der antarktis es gab ja auch experimente mit diesem isolierten biosphäre also vor allem dieses.
Beides vier tu biosphäre zwei projekte
das wäre eins ist sozusagen die erde und dann gab's in arizona war das glaube ich in den usa den versuch dort.
So eine biosphäre zu machen also natürlich jetzt nicht nur mit einzelnen pflanzen sondern eben mit tieren menschen pflanzen aller art.
Da wird jetzt oft gesagt das wäre ja gescheitert aber so was gibt's eigentlich 'ne wissenschaft nicht mal hat mir herausgefunden welche schwierigkeiten sich aus so einer geplanten isolierung geben ist das ein wichtiges experiment
gewesen für die forschung auf das feld da.
Also das war ein enorm wichtiges experiment auch vor allem es gibt kein scheitern in der wissenschaft sondern ähm.
Auch wenn man das ziel nicht erreicht hat was man sich ursprünglich vorgenommen hat ein autarkes ökosystem zu entwickeln.
Man hat aber vieles gelernt dabei man hat vieles gelernt weil man gemerkt hat dass die der sauerstoffgehalt innerhalb dieser.
Kuppel also vielleicht kurz zur erklärung bei uns vier ist eine abgeschlossene kuppel eine glaskugel in der wüste von arizona und in dieser kuppel hat man.
Unterschiedlichste biologische systeme zusammengebracht soweit man es wusste bis zu dem zeitpunkt.
In der ökosystem der erde ist ein äußerst komplexes system das heißt wir haben immer ein zusammenspiel zwischen konsumenten.
Produzenten und auch die drohenden also die tränen sind mikroben also diejenigen die sozusagen die kleinsten bestandteile wieder zerlegen verwertbaren bestandteile in nährstoffe zerlegen die pflanzen brauchen diese nährstoffe wiederum um zu wachsen und äh
pflanzen werden dann entweder von tieren gegessen oder von menschen und der mensch ist wiederum die tiere oder eben dann die pflanzen der mensch wiederum hat seine hinterlassenschaften seine.
Ja sozusagen seinen output der wiederum dann von den mikroben zersetzt wird und dieser kreislauf der funktioniert auf der erde sehr gut wir haben riesige prophetie kapazitäten,
wir haben wahnsinnig ein wahnsinnig vielfältiges.
Ökosystem und jetzt hat man versucht dieses ökosystem abzubilden möglichst einfach abzubilden in bayern für zwei hat sich bestimmte bestimmte tiere bestimmte,
pflanzen und bestimmte mikroben auch ausgesucht die dann dort ein dort dann auch beheimatet wurden und dann hat man dieses.
Experiment begonnen in der hoffnung dass man hier ein gleichgewicht hat ein gleichgewicht zwischen den gesamten stoff strömen den energie,
strömen also den strahlung einfluss von der sonne der auch wo wir ein tag nach zirkus haben auch wärme eingetragen wird und gleichzeitig natürlich auch dass die ganzen die ganzen.
Stofflichen umsätze zueinander passen als mensch wartet man atmen man zum beispiel ein kilogramm zwei am tag aus und braucht hingegen achthundertvierzig gramm sauerstoff am tag.
Passt das alles,
und am schluss man hat das experiment dann abgebrochen weil der sauerstoffgehalt in der luft im in bayern für zwo immer weiter nach unten gegangen ist wobei ursächlich originär ursächlich dafür war dann eine.
Beton mischung die man verwendet hat beim aufbau von bayers für zwei wonach und nach.
Dann sauerstoff gebunden würde wurde in diesem betonen aber nichtsdestotrotz hat man auch gesehen dass innerhalb der der mikroben landschaft bestimmte spezies dann dominierend wurden und andere ihr ähm.
Unterdrückt wurden
wo man dann nach und nach versucht hat auch erklärungen dafür zu finden welche parameter waren dafür entscheiden man hat doch auch gemerkt so auf die schnelle schafft man es nicht ein ökosystem künstlich nach zu bilden dabei sind diese ähm
experimente aber sehr wichtig gewesen weil sie bilden die voraussetzung für andere fördern auf aufbauende experimente es gibt zum beispiel die melissa plant von der esa
wurde mitte der neunziger dann entwickelt und inzwischen steht in der nähe von barcelona äh steht ähm ja ein wunderbarer.
Eine wunderbare forschungseinrichtung wo gerade auch dieser kreislauf den ich eingangs beschrieben habe zwischen.
Konsumenten produzenten und auch zerlegen.
Wo das eingehen studiert wird mit einzelnen mikroorganismen und sobald die erkenntnis da ist wie man auch mit diesen einzelnen organismus mit umgeht schaltet man diese schrittweise zusammen und hofft so dann von diesem ähm.
Von diesem button dann nach und nach ein geschlossenes system zusammen schalten zu können von dem her ist jedes experiment was man.
Was man hier macht auch und das zur schließung des kreislauf beiträgt ist es immer ein gutes experiment selbst wenn man jetzt nicht.
Das gewünschte ziel was man sich original vorgenommen hat noch nicht erreicht hat.
Das halte ich für sehr wichtig und dass das schule gemacht hat geschlossener kreislauf läufe intensiv zu untersuchen sind wir auch in china dort wurde der luna palace aufgebaut der im prinzip nachbilden soll wie sieht denn eine ähm
wie sieht eine mond station aus und mit welchem lebensjahr haltungssystem technologien müssen wir dort arbeiten luna palace als forschungs- plattform.
Und das sind eben die chinesen auch pfiffig dabei und die russen hatten auch ein ähnliches experiment das war das bei uns drei
experiment also von dem her jede raumfahrt nation hat zu ihrer eigenen ich sag mal auch schon ihre eigenen gehversuche gemacht oder macht sie auch immer noch was das schließen von kreislauf läufen angeht und das funktioniert aber nur wenn wir die biologie mit den,
holen mit rein.
Technischen also chemischen und physikalischen prozessen kommen wir da nicht weiter und das hängt einig und einzig und allein nur damit zusammen dass es keinen technischen prozess gibt.
Um aus um aus dem kohlenstoff einen wieder verwertbaren stoff für die.
Für die sogenannten konsumenten also den mensch oder auch gegebenenfalls die tiere zu machen also ganz einfaches beispiel die pflanzen nehmen das c o zwei auf,
binden es in ihrer biomasse und wir können anschließend die biomasse wieder essen das kann kein anderes technisches system bis zum heutigen tage.
Also bis in die quadratur des kreises im prinzip die natur zumindest soweit abzubilden und genau diese drei stufen sozusagen eines zyklus erfolgreich nach zu bilden also man hat sozusagen den konsum ich esse irgendetwas
die ausscheidungen die dann aber wiederum,
überführt werden müssen in etwas anderes aus dem dann wieder pflanzen wachsen können damit sich dann quasi einen dritten stufe die,
die erste wieder anschließen kann.
Das so ein bisschen der heilige gral eigentlich in der ja jetzt hätte ich fast astro biologie gesagt das ist glaube ich nicht der richtige begriff was gibt es denn überhaupt einen guten begriff für.
Pflanzen forschung für weltraum einsatz sich noch gar nicht so richtig etabliert oder.
Na nicht im speziellen aber ähm man kann durchaus für den weltraum biologie sprechen das wird 's eigentlich ganz gut charakterisiert.
Ich würde tatsächlich aber so von der ingenieur seite kommen und auch noch ergänzen
wenn man sich mal anschaut was was für was für management systeme brauche ich eigentlich um den menschen im weltraum am leben zu
ich muss schauen dass nahrung bereitgestellt wird dass luft bereitgestellt wird
wasser bereitgestellt wird und die abfälle entsorgt werden damit haben sie eigentlich schon mal alle vier die die vier wichtigsten aufgaben eines lebens erhaltung systems abgedeckt müssen natürlich auch dafür sorgen dass die sicherheit der astronauten gewährleistet ist
die luft aufbereitung kriegen wir technisch in die wasser aufbereitung kriegen wir auch technisch hin die abfall sammlung kriegen wir auch technisch in die nahrungsbrei stellung
gelingt uns aber nur indem wir permanent nachschub bringen und genau da liegt äh sozusagen der heilige gral drinne dort brauchen wir unbedingt die biologie
und wenn wir aber die biologie mit ins boot nehmen dann kaufen wir nicht nur die nahrungsbrei t stellung mit ein sondern dann kaufen wir uns und das ist äh die synergie in diesem ganzen thema kaufen wir uns auch luft generell generation mit ein und gleichzeitig noch ähm.
Diesen psychologischen effekt den ich vorher schon angesprochen habe dass man sich freut wenn man auch pflanzen seiner näheren umgebung hat um die man sich kümmern darf.
Ich hatte michael vor zweieinhalb jahren schon ein zweites mal mit santa christopher ready unterhalten die
italienische esa astronauten die expedition zweiundvierzig oben war wenn man sich auf so ein gespräch vorbereitet
versucht man sich viele fragen einfallen zu lassen die vielleicht erstens nicht auch alle schon gestellt haben die vielleicht nicht unbedingt so das naheliegende sind mir fällt gerade ein dass sie für relativ wenig über essen und lebenshaltung gesprochen haben dafür aber viel über gerüche
das wäre wahrscheinlich ganz klug gewesen.
Denn man muss sich ja mal klar machen wir eigentlich situationen da oben ist man denkt sich immer so ja klar ja so leben da oben und so bloß auch der mensch braucht ja
ein.
Biorhythmus sozusagen nicht nur rechtzeitig aufstehen und wieder schlafen gehen sondern so ein astronaut muss versorgt werden ich glaube man muss sowieso knapp dreieinhalb tonnen.
Lebensmittel.
Aufwenden und irgendwie so sechs astronauten ein jahr lang dort am leben zu erhalten und wieso was so anderthalb kilo glaube ich pro tag aber die essen ja sozusagen nur.
Trocken nahrung die ganze zeit oder.
Ja das ist richtig und das ich sag mal so für diese für diese dauer wo die astronauten derzeit auf der eis sind dass das ganze irgendwo noch in einem zuträglich den und dem
angemessenen rahmen zu sehen und die astronauten werden ja darauf auch vorbereitet aber ganz wichtig ist wenn man die frage stellt äh wie soll denn das ganze auf eine maß mission auch aussehen,
wenn man wirklich zwei zweieinhalb jahre nur von von fertig essen von trockenen nahrung auch sich ernähren,
schwierige frage ich glaube dass wir hier nicht um hinkommen auch mit biologischen systemen zu arbeiten mit pflanzen zu arbeiten die man dann auch ernten kann worauf man sich auch mal ein frisches essen zubereiten kann das hat auch was dann mit äh mit motivation zu tun
das.
Psychologische wirkung des frischen salat platz die wir schon.
Ganz richtig und es war auch eines der aussagen die von alexander gerst kam also wieder von seiner letzten
zurück kam das erste auf dass er sich gefreut hat das war eine frische pizza und da merkt man einfach wie dieser dieser wunsch dieser wunsch nach frischem essen nach frisch zubereiten essen.
In den vordergrund tritt je länger man in so einer zu einem in so einer isolierten umgebung auch lebt
und wenn jetzt jemand mal ein halbes jahr auf der ist oder vielleicht noch ein paar monate mehr dann kann man damit irgendwie sich noch noch noch damit abfinden und das irgendwie auch noch aushalten.
Wenn sie aber gerade eben richtung richtung langzeit explotion gehen oder wir wollen auf dem auf der mond oberfläche
eine eine station aufbauen die dann langzeit bewohnt ist.
Dann müssen wir unbedingt pflanzen oder biologische systeme im allgemeinen mitdenken und auch was gerüche angeht tragen pflanzen auch zu einem angenehmen klima bei das.
Können sie ganz ganz einfach auch bei sich zu hause oder bei sich im büro feststellen wenn das fenster mal ein zwei tage nicht öffnen.
Nicht öffnen und nur vielleicht die tür einen spalt offen halten damit der cdu zwei gehalt nicht so hoch wird sie merken es wird unangenehm einfach vom geruch her wird es unangenehm.
Und wir haben jetzt zwar auf der eine luft aufbereitung anlage.
Die auch dafür sorgt dass durch diverse filter gerüche mikroben und so weiter minimiert werden aber das kriegen sie nicht komplett raus.
Pflanzen bieten da eben durch auch durch die eigene transpiration durch das eigene freisetzen noch von von wasserdampf und auch die aufnahme von unterschiedlichsten,
bindungen chemischen verbindungen ermöglichen die eben auch noch in eine bereitstellung eines guten luft klimas
und das hat man bisher noch nicht näher studiert also gerade im wasser was jetzt die große skalierbarkeit auch angeht da ist aber noch eben auch ein richtig schöner seiten aspekt zu sehen.
Stimmt eigentlich ne also ich meine wenn man sich dieses irgendwie da dieses dieses gefühl erinnert was man sofort bekommt wenn man in dem fall geht.
Dann ist es ja nicht nur kühler sondern es ist halt einfach dieses diese diese gesamte nicht nur der geruch ist so diese.
Im idealfall perfekt ermutigende perfektes komisches wort aber.
Es ist so so umfänglich also die feuchtigkeit die gerüche
alles hat irgendwie ist auf irgendeine art und weise so rund wie man es dann eben an den,
indem wir uns normalerweise aufhalten ja auch schon sehr technisch viert oder eben auch teilweise sehr isoliert sind so überhaupt nicht vorfindet ne oder,
um das andere beispiel nochmal aufzugreifen so zu hause wenn man das fenster nicht aufmacht hat man aber jetzt die wohnung voller pflanzen sie das ja dann auch schon wieder ganz anders aus,
also darum wollte ich eigentlich vorhin auch nochmal hinaus und die situation der astronauten auf der ist sie sind ja in dieser maschine das muss
mal macht man sich irgendwie auch nicht klar dass man eigentlich die ganze zeit in einer maschine ist sozusagen in dem lebens feindlichen umgebung die man sich eigentlich überhaupt nur vorstellen kann und es ist ja nicht nur das essen
oder eben auch die gerüche sondern auch das was man,
atmet also der der körper versucht ja nach wie vor eins zu sein mit seiner umgebung nur diese umgebung schafft es irgendwie nicht so richtig eins zu sein mit mit meinem körper.
Ich vermute jetzt mal das sind auch alles so aspekte die in dieser pflanzen forschung,
auch eine rolle spielen also es geht ja nicht nur darum pflanzen zu essen sondern genauso könnten ja pflanzen auch,
die luft dort verbessern beziehungsweise vielleicht ja auch technische systeme ersetzen oder zumindest ergänzen.
Also ganz wichtig ist immer wenn man darüber streitet oder auch darüber diskutiert und zwar hart diskutiert in der wissenschaftlichen welt welche.
Prozesse und welche techniken setze ich ein um welche aufgabe in dem lebenshaltung system zu erfüllen da spielt in allererster linie erstmal wie schwer ist unser gerät wie viel kostet die wartung wie viel kostet die wartung.
Wie viel energiebedarf liegt liegt steht steckt dahinter und wie ist der kühlung bedarf zu sehen und das ganze bildet sozusagen eine gewisse ja eine gewisse
weise auf techniken und dann nimmt diese nüchternen nüchternen.
Parameter versucht man zu bewerten wann man welche technologie einsetzt diese weichen parameter wie eben die psychologie für die astronauten die.
Ja ich sag mal die durch die verbesserung des geruch s wenn eben pflanzen vor ort sind das sind erstmal die wände erstmal zweitrangig bewertet ganz wichtig ist am anfang wenn eben also eine mission auch geplant wird zum beispiel richtung nass.
Mit welchem technologien erreiche ich welche aufgabe und wenn es um die luft bereitstellung geht wenn es um die nahrungsbrei t stellung geht dann konkurrieren ja auch biologische systeme mit den bisher technischen und chemisch physikalischen technologien
und wenn hier dann die vorteile der biologischen systeme überwiegen wenn auch die parameter für sich sprechen wenn es also am schluss
günstiger ist und auch finanziell darstellbar ist und auch von der ganzen maintenance und im power bedarf darstellbar ist dann entscheidet man sich auch für das biologische system.
An dem sind wir heute noch nicht was die ganzen studien und experimente angeht im moment.
Sind tatsächlich immer die chemisch physikalischen systeme machen das rennen bei dieser bewertung hängt aber auch damit zusammen dass technische systeme einfach nochmal vierzig jahre mehr entwicklungs- zeit bisher hatten
das heißt wenn wenn es heute darum geht einfach nur ein verfahren zu ignorieren um zwei herauszufiltern.
Da werden sie ein technisches system nehmen ein technisches system bestehend auseinander aus dem filteranlage aus einem prozess und anschließend noch mit einer aus einem elektrolyte prozess und dann.
Prozessor.
Ein prozess der prozess
erzeugnis sozusagen eine aufs spaltung von kohlendioxid in wasserstoff und in ähm.
Meter an und das metall an und das liegt eigentlich schon wieder da da kann man dann wieder sehr schön sehen das metall.
Kann man natürlich den kohlenstoff nochmal abspalten habe ich den wasserstoff wieder zurück aber das c c bleibt bei so einem bei so einer technischen komponente immer übrig
und wenn man diesen kompletten kreislauf anguckt aus dem wasserstoff kann man dann wiederum beziehungsweise aus dem wasser kann man dann wieder wasserstoff und sauerstoff erzeugen gewinnt sozusagen seinen sauerstoff wieder aus dem c o zwei zurück aber der kohlenstoff bleibt immer übrig
je nachdem wie wie ich meine frage stelle ich möchte nur eine zwei filteranlage oder eine sauerstoff zurückgewinnen anlage
dann würde ich mich für den technischen prozess entscheiden wenn wir aber die nahrungsbrei stellung wichtig ist
dann fällt dort der kohlenstoff als abfall an und da können die biologischen komponenten daneben punkten und das ist eben dann nachher in der abwägung in der bewertung der einzelnen
komponenten enorm wichtig und was wiegt es nachher am ende wie viel masse muss ich eben hier von der erde aus in den weltraum bringen damit ich ein funktionierendes system.
Ja in unserer niedrigen erst um laufbahn habe von wo aus ich dann die reise richtung aus antreten also das sind so ein bisschen die schlüsselfrage die dann die raumfahrt agenturen auch steh stellen werden wie viel masse kostet es mich
die hier vom boden.
In die niedrige laufbahn bringen muss in den in den leo um von dort aus dann anschließend die reise anzutreten also hier steckt ja auch wirklich die der größte einsatz an energie um die masse vom boden in den weltraum zu bringen
und das müssen sie dann aber auch über die gesamte mission sich anschauen sich anschauen das heißt habe ich über den.
Über den gesamten missionswerk zeitraum habe ich danach eine masse einsparung oder eben eigentlich einen zusätzlichen masse bitte aufwendig biologische systeme einsätze ganz einfach formuliert wenn sie sich dafür entscheiden
nahrungs allem die gesamte den gesamten nahrungsbrei darf über den nachschub oder über das mitnehmen zu decken
müssen sie das alles am anfang mit auf ihre mission nehmen.
Oder immer wieder nachliefern also bei langzeit mission muss man halt alles mitnehmen.
Da muss man alles mitnehmen und wenn die systeme haben die das ihnen vor ort produzieren,
da müssen sie sich auf der anderen seite gedanken machen okay dafür ist das system größer aber wiegt es sozusagen ist unterm strich dann trotzdem günstiger nach der gesamten mission zeit und ich muss im gegenzug aber natürlich noch,
düker mitnehmen also ein organische substrat oder anorganischen stoffe sofern ich sie nicht aus einem anderen prozess zurückgewinnen kann und das wird eben sehr sehr spannend da werden wir noch viele diskussionen führen werden
bist du eine bemannten maß mission oder langzeit mission und langzeit expo ration ähm bis sie auch dann mal technisch
soweit skizziert sind ja wohl in diese richtung soll's dann auch gehen.
Ich finde das alles so anhöre mich das am laufenden meter auch so an aktuelle diskussion rund um den klimawandel und die möglichkeit,
der gewinnung also der.
Rückführung von co zwei in was auch immer für zustände grad im rahmen dieser klima kompensation wenn er nicht nur jetzt so reine renaturierung prozesse äh durchgeführt sondern eben auch technische anlagen die das
durchführen beziehungsweise eben damit auch verbunden die ganze frage des
wirtschaftlichen kreislauf wie machen wir das mit brennstoffen gelingt es in irgendeiner form über diesen ähnlichen
kreislauf mit metall und der weiteren auf spaltung kohlenstoff etcetera da sozusagen eine so ein premium der der stoffe herzustellen womit ja vielleicht sogar auch denkbar wäre mit verbrennungsmotoren weiterzuarbeiten solange sie eben nicht,
fossile energien verbrennen es ist ja alles gar nicht so schlimm sozusagen jetzt von den
schadstoffen die in dem prozess vielleicht auch noch produziert werden mal ganz abgesehen ist denn diese forschung die wir jetzt hier die ganze zeit skizziert haben davon noch.
Separat oder ist das schon auch etwas was in irgendeiner form zueinander findet.
Das muss heute auch immer zueinander finden also alles was wir in der raumfahrt ähm entwickeln
alles was auch insbesondere auch in der bemannten raumfahrt entwickelt wird man sucht ja immer nach spin-off auch für den äh für die anwendung und.
Gerade dieser spin-off genannt gedanke welchen nutzen und wert hat die gesamte raumfahrt forschung auch für die gesellschaft der muss auch
bei allen raumfahrt projekten die wir heute die wir heute tun immer mit beantwortet werden oder zumindest mal ab geschätzt werden,
sie können natürlich auch alles was sie heute in der raumfahrt entwickeln nicht immer unbedingt gleich absehen was kann was könnte daraus in fünf bis zehn jahren für ein spin-off entstehen aber man muss sich zumindest gedanken machen und das finde ich im grundsatz und ähm auch richtig.
Weil letztlich raumfahrt projekte kosten immer sehr sehr viel geld,
sind also auch nicht nur losgelöst rein wissenschaftlich zu sehen wir wollen ähm unser wissen vermehren sondern sind eben auch durchaus politisch zu sehen das heißt was wollen wir als gesellschaft auch und wie viel geld wollen wir den investieren
nicht umsonst ist gerade jetzt eben in deutschland das raumfahrt budget beim bundesministerium für wirtschaft und technologie angesiedelt
und dort wird eben dann auch eingefordert was bringt uns als gesellschaft die diese forschung und da wird es eben gerade interessant
klimawandel auch ansprechen.
Rein technisch und physikalisch gesehen gibt es schon ganz viele antworten auf die fragen die man im bezug auf den klimawandel haben ressourcen schonung co zwei vermeidung abkehr von der verbrennung fossile rohstoffe ähm.
Diese themen also diese fragestellungen sind eigentlich physikalisch und auch technisch beantwortet bar und machbar.
Die frage die man jetzt eben stellt wie transformiert man das auf den großen gebrauch auf die skalierbarkeit ist immer noch mal was anderes wenn sie den prozess bei sich im labor machen oder auf der betreiben auf der eises wird das arbeitsprozess betrieben um dort wo zwei
dann eben auf zu spalten und wasser und.
Aber was bedeutet das in groß technischen maßstab und vor allem wie teuer wird das ganze und das ist eben gerade im politischen kontext und auch in gesellschaftlichen kontext da werden sie sofort immer gefragt was kostet es der klimawandel diese diskussion reduziert sich ja.
Nicht oder die diskussion wird er nicht auf der ebene geführt was bedeutet für unsere artenvielfalt was für.
Eventuell flüchtlingsbewegung werden sich werden daraus entstehen in zukunft ähm auf dem globus sondern es wird immer gefragt was kostet das ganze oder was kostet das ganze wenn wir es nicht wenn wir wenn wir uns nicht
gegen den klimawandel stemmen das heißt die frage in brennt sich immer was kostet es und
diese antwort die muss politisch beantwortet werden die kann gar nicht mehr technisch oder auch wissenschaftlich beantwortet werden wir als wissenschaftler und da schließe ich mich jetzt einfach
auch als oberbürgermeister mit ein als wissenschaftler liefert man die daten dafür.
Und was man daraus macht welche konsequenzen welche politischen man konsequenzen man daraus ableitet das ist dann nachher politik zwar ein kleiner ab.
Finde ich überhaupt nicht nee das ist so muss man das glaube ich auch betrachten final wieder ein sodass man bald vor so einer situation stehen könnte wo man gefragt wird so ja warum auf den planeten nicht gerettet ja war zu teuer.
So und das funktioniert halt.
Vor dem vor dieser frage habe ich in vierzig jahren könnte die frage durchaus mal so lauten.
Ohne jetzt da ein angst szenario auszumachen aber die szenarien die auch entwickelt werden von wissenschaftlern die sehen ja auch eine gewisse bandbreite form und äh ich sag mal das video
eltern ein aber wir sollten nichtsdestotrotz ist was mario im kopf haben und in unseren handlungen durchaus ähm auch als referenz heranziehen.
Und deshalb finde ich auch umso wichtiger alles was wir bekommen von den alles was wir bekommen von.
Ein wissenschaftlichen input des entsprechenden auch ordentlich zu bewerten und gerade die pflanzen biologie um mal wieder so den bogen nochmal zu spannend.
Die pflanzen biologie bietet unheimlich spannende ergebnisse wie wir und was wir auch für unsere erde,
können was wir auch in unserem täglichen handeln hier ableiten können und das tut eigentlich umso mehr weh wenn man sieht wie beispielsweise regenwald täglich verloren geht oder auch,
ja eigentlich nicht gerade verantwortungsvoll wir mit der versiegelung unserer flächen umgehen und da müssen wir schon
mehr dazu lernen müssen effizienter werden müssen aber auch tatsächlich die kosten im blick behalten und um das im blick zu behalten haben wir gibt es eben technische lösungen.
Ja und es gibt auch noch ganz interessante experimente die man vielleicht auch nochmal erwähnen sollte ich glaube eins was auch seit gar nicht lange zeit im alles ist das projekt,
krupp es von vom wdr was ich aus einem ganz anderen.
Auch ganz interessant finde also das ganze ist ein kleinster lied in dem halt auch so ein zyklus prozess
getestet wird und er hat so einen schönen science-fiction
das ist glaube ich der erste satellit ist der tatsächlich so eine künstliche schwerkraft herstellt es hat mir anfangs die ganze zeit diskutiert über naja wie machen wir das alles sozusagen ohne schwerkraft weil die jetzt so herzustellen hat sich ja im großen maßstab zumindest noch nicht so ganz als.
Praktisch erwiesen also zweitausendeins hat das ja immer so schön vorgeführt so hier raumstation und da kann man dann irgendwie auch immer schön im kreis joggen weil ich die ganze zeit da was bewegt
wird aber normalerweise nicht gemacht weil zu anfällig zu aufwendig zu teuer et cetera pp hier allerdings kleinste format ist das durchaus gemacht worden
frage ich mich natürlich warum eigentlich schwerkraft erzeugen im all die quasi unten schon kostenlos hat was das für ein projekt was versucht das für.
Interessante aspekte hervorzubringen.
Bei europas geht es auch um die schließung von stoff kreisläufe bei europas geht es auch darum die mit mikro algen und mit pflanzen zu arbeiten und ähm gerade dieses
gleichgewicht äh dieses gleichgewicht zu studieren ist es möglich ist es möglich dieses biologische system in einem in einem gleichgewicht zu operieren zu betreiben
und zum einen unter schwerkraft einfluss erzeugung künstlicher schwache künstlicher schwerkraft.
Durch rotation und auf der anderen seite natürlich auch unter schwerelosigkeit das heißt wenn sich eben der satellit.
Das heißt man hat eine hervorragende voraussetzung und für referenz experimente sich das ganze näher anzuschauen und vor allem ist es eben jetzt auch wieder genau diese parallele zu dem experiment ist eine isolierten.
Ich kann da jetzt nicht eingreifen und man macht ja wirklich nach dem nach dem besten wissen.
Was man aus der wissenschaft kennt bereitet man diese experimente vor und möchte dann auch zeigen wenn es dann.
Erfolgreich ist jawohl wir haben unser system verstanden
und da arbeitet man dann auch daraufhin dass da bearbeitet auch grobes oder viele andere experimente darauf hin,
wenn man es verstanden hat wie diese stoff kreisläufe funktionieren und ein laufendes system man gefunden und entwickelt hat auf dem kann man dann wieder weiter aufbauen und das ist ganz ganz wichtig
weil gerade dieses deswegen war am anfang gehört haben.
Salut eins da ging doch alles schief da hat man noch viele gehversuche machen müssen oder nicht alles ging schief sondern hat vieles gelernt was man eben noch nicht berücksichtigt hat und so fängt man an schritt für schritt
die,
einzelnen äh die einzelnen prozesse zu kennen und da ist auch durchaus ähm steckt immer der teufel ein bisschen im detail auf der einen seite möchte man die biologischen fragestellungen die bio prozesse konkret kennenlernen und dann aber auch die die gast transfers die transfers von einzelnen stoffen
zur nächsten
schritt untersuchen aber zum anderen diesen geschlossener kreislauf auch ähm aufrecht erhalten so dass es eben ein in sich geschlossenes autarkes system ist und da finde ich leistet europa ist auch 'ne hervorragenden beitrag.
Das ist ein ganz wichtiges system also das mit der schwerkraft seine optional also kann man einschalten kann man aber auch konfigurieren wie man's denn gerne hätte also.
So eine einstellung da hat man so mond schwerkraft dann hat man nur die maß schwerkraft also man kann sozusagen denselben prozess
immer wieder nachbilden oder verschiedenen gravitationswellen jungen.
Und da wird wird auch deutlich
diese erzeugung von künstlicher schwerkraft ähm von dem hat man sich zum beispiel im niedrigen erdogan mit verabschiedet das macht man nicht weil man mit dem später schwerelosigkeit gut zurecht kommt aber wenn wir auf langzeit missionen geht.
Brauchen wir eine künstliche schwerkraft brauchen wir eine umgebung wo wir schwerkraft bereitstellen,
weil es größere weil die vorteile einfach überlegen wenn wir mit den gewohnten mechanismen die wir hier von der erde auch kennen,
arbeiten können wenn wir die schwerkraft auch uns zunutze machen können im gegensatz zu einer schwere losen umgebung und vor allem bereitet man sich auch darauf vor richtung maß oberfläche und richtung mond oberfläche.
Mond oberfläche mit einem sechstel unserer schwerkraft wir haben immerhin noch etwas schwerkraft aber das reicht aus um
die biologie der biologie auch zu sagen oder der dass die biologie entsprechend darauf reagiert aufgrund ihrer ihrer gravitation bis ähm.
Die eben in den pflanzen vorhanden ist.
Da scheint ja so ein bisschen das aktuelle mega ziel zu sein der,
der mond also man hört es eigentlich in allen bereichen ist es sowohl auf der raumfahrt politischen ebenen heißes ding welche mission werden hier unternommen man merkt,
auch dass gerade die neuen space startup sich auch extrem auf dem mond fokussieren da scheint das ja
mit den pflanzen auch nochmal eine besondere bedeutung erlangen zu können weil der mond ja im prinzip auch so dieses versprechen hat na ja okay das ist jetzt für uns der erreichbar ist der ort
sich dort aufzuhalten
also zumindest technisch dauerhaft aufzuhalten vielleicht eben auch mit menschen zumindest bei einem bestimmten zeitraum länger aufzuhalten.
Zahlreiche verheißung im bezug auf vorbereitung von mission ja was wäre wenn man dort hinfahren kann
und von dort aus starten kann dass man quasi erstmal das ganze zubehör sammelt dann vom mond aus weiter fliegt oder zumindest irgendwelche versorgung einheiten macht oder eben dann mit dem wasser auf dem.
Mond auch gibt in solche gewächshäuser
betreibt wenn man auch mal die zeit fiction schauen ja ja ganz am anfang schon den einfluss von filmen ich erinnere mich an diverse filme ich kann's jetzt grad nicht alle benennen die halt so diese
gemüse parks und diese,
garten landschaften immer teil von solchen station hat was ganz bemerkenswert finde generell meine diese funktion ist ja letzten endes auch so ein bisschen der gedanken nahrungs lieferant auch für die forschung weil man denkt sich halt erstmal aus was wäre wenn und dann
spannende
quasi das was früher mal fiction war ein realität zu überführen aber ich glaube so wenn man so ganz allgemein erstmal ein raumfahrt denkt dann ist halt immer das reine fliegen und erreichen das steht immer so ein bisschen im vordergrund aber sie selbst ernähren eigentlich selten
ein thema wie.
Kommen wir denn sozusagen da jetzt hin oder anders gefragt wie weit sind wir davon noch entfernt was muss jetzt eigentlich noch
gelernt werden und in dem zusammenhang vielleicht was muss auch erforscht werden um solche mission vielleicht nehmen wir erstmal nur mal den mond weil ich halte das ein gewisser hinsicht für realistischer
die maß expedition die vielleicht irgendwann auch in der zukunft nochmal stattfinden wird was wie nah dran sind wir an dem ganzen prozess.
Also es geht im kern darum können wir dauerhaft biologische biologische systeme auch betreiben.
Also wenn ich jetzt eine pflanze kultivieren sei es eine tomate oder seines mikro algen oder salat.
Dass ich auch permanent die versorgung von astronauten auf sicherstellen.
An dem muss man weiterarbeiten da ist man noch nicht so weit dass man das permanent auch kann also wirklich diese kontinuierliche erfüllung des anspruchs den ähm ein astronaut auch hat
und gleichzeitig auch noch bei möglichst niedrigem wartung auf.
Das heißt man schaut dass möglichst viel dann auch automatisiert wird und diese ganzen experimente die man jetzt sei es jetzt eure grobes oder auch auf der die man äh die man unternommen hat oder auch noch unternehmen wird das sind alles vorbereitende experimente.
Die mond oberfläche bietet jetzt erstmalig auch 'ne möglichkeit unter einem schwerkraft einfluss unter einem niedrigeren schwerkraft einfluss.
Die kultiviert in einer isolierten umgebung ähnlich wie in der antarktis aber doch nochmal ein bisschen anders nämlich reduzierte schwerkraft und erhöhter strahlung einfluss.
Dort die pflanzen kultivierung die ja die bereitstellung auch von nahrung nochmal näher zu studieren ich kann mir gut vorstellen dass das ganze baustein artig auch ähm passieren wird.
Am anfang wird man klar auf seine.
Technischen ähm auf sein technisches know-how zurückgreifen das heißt physikalisch chemische prozesse werden für die lebenshaltung der astronauten eingesetzt werden und man wird erstmal die biologie als.
Experimentiert feld verstehen das heißt man baut mal schrittweise
eine salat maschine oder einen foto bio reaktor für die mikro alpen kultivierung auf und sobald man eine sicherheit bekommen hat ein gespür dafür bekommen hat ok das ganze system ist stabil es ist zuverlässig es ist resilient auch gegenüber störungen
dann wagen wir uns das ganze system in das eigentliche lebenshaltung system zu integrieren und können dann nach und nach auch äh vielleicht teile des.
Physikalisch chemischen systems auch zurückfahren wenn nicht sogar vielleicht auch irgendwann abschalten und dieser prozess.
Möchte jetzt da keine vorausschau wagen wie lange sowas brauchen wird aber das wird die voraussetzung sein das wird nicht von heute auf morgen jawohl das zu stellen wir ein
biologische system hin und dann wird fotosynthese betrieben mit diesem biologischen system und dann werden wird sauerstoff erzeugt und wird nahrungsmittel bereitgestellt
am anfang wird es auch so wie wir es von der kennen sehr ähnlich sein und dann werden nach und nach die biologischen systeme ergänzt und gleichzeitig bietet das auch.
Die voraussetzung um in richtung maß mission zu denken bietet auch die voraussetzung in richtung therapieformen zu denken
wenn man bedenkt sechsundneunzig prozent der maß atmosphäre zwar bei einem enormen niedrigen ähm gesamteindruck von nur vier milli bar ähm
kann man sich aber durchaus vorstellen pflanzen für ein für therapieformen einzusetzen das heißt wie kann man denn auch beispielsweise eine maß oberfläche um so ein bisschen im science-fiction bereich zu bleiben wie könnte man dann auch wieder die den mars als bewohnbar planeten zurückgewinnen.
Das ist aber sehr.
Gerne drauf eigentlich wollte ich nochmal kurz auf den,
montag bleiben einfach nur das mal so durchzuspielen also gehen wir jetzt mal von von limitierten finanziellen förderung und unlimitiertes der politische bereitschaft aus.
Ich weiß es jetzt der unrealistische teil aber.
Aber 'ne schöne voraussetzung.
Ja einfach nur mal irgendwann auch mal so ein bisschen gradmesser dafür zu bekommen was hätten wir denn sozusagen schon und was was fehlt uns dennoch vollständig wie das richtig sehe auf dem mond müsste man doch im prinzip
am pool solche stationen einrichten einerseits
wenn man weiß dass es dort wasser gibt andererseits bayer der mond nun die sonnenbestrahlung
immer zwei wochen hat und dann zwei wochen nicht als würde man jetzt sozusagen an der vorder- oder rückseite sich
platzieren als rückseite macht natürlich wenig sinn aber würde man so die klassischen mondlandung station nehmen die orte wo man also schon runtergekommen ist hätte man halt zwei wochen lang hitze und zwei wochen totale.
Kälte.
Ist halt nicht so gut wenn man jetzt oben am pool gehen könnte man ja sozusagen immer so sich so an diesem punkt bewegen wo mehr oder weniger auch schon so eine mittlere einstreu zahlung stattfinden.
Am südpol hat man beispielsweise die sogenannten peace.
Also die spitzen der unendlichen beleuchtung also wirklich dort wo aufgrund der demographischen gegebenheiten man auch nahezu eine vollständige permanente solarien strahlung hat.
Das sind sehr spannende das sind sehr spannende regionen die auch da in den fokus rücken ob.
Auch persönlich permanent es sich permanent nieder lässt äh wir haben das auch schon,
am institut untersucht im rahmen von unserem sogenannten space station design workshops,
und das ist natürlich sehr verheißungsvoll weil ich permanent solarium strahlung hab zur energieerzeugung sehr sehr sehr sehr sehr sehr sinnvoll und auch vorteilhaft
und gleichzeitig auch sehr vorteilhaft eben um fotosynthese zu betreiben allerdings natürlich sehr herausfordernd was das thermal management ausgeht also das sind ja so ein bisschen technische fragestellung aber tatsächlich
also technische fragestellungen abwägen ob man dann eher an mit montag geht oder in den pool.
Eine option.
Der vater ist nach wie vor eine option.
Aber da immer noch zwei wochen lang irgendwie licht aus.
Das.
Kann auch ein vorteil sein.
Könnt ihr auch ein vorteil sein ja also das das hängt davon ab wie stell ich meine energie nachher bereit,
das heißt auch für pflanzen ich muss sie künstlich beleuchten das muss man am schluss äh muss man dann am schluss zusammenrechnen und mal ganz einfach gesprochen wie viel masse brauche ich um so eine mond statt sondern eine permanente mond station
am montag vater zu platzieren und wieviel am wie viel kostet das eben dass am pool zu machen.
Lieber wärmer ist unlimitiertes finanzielle ressourcen habe ich ja gesagt.
Ja ja.
Ja so richtig aus dem vollen schöpfen.
Also ich würde tendenziell dorthin gehen wo wo ein wasser vorkommen vermutet wird dann bin ich in der polar region dort hat man wasser wasser ist auch so ein,
so ein element was uns dann was uns viele nachschub missionen einsparen würde
das wäre sehr spannend um eine sehr spannende option nur allein jetzt dass wir wissen dass es dort vorkommt wissen wir noch nicht so viel darüber wie groß sind die
wie groß ist die kapazität die wir dort haben aber grundsätzlich kann man sich das äh kann man sich das natürlich gut äh gut vorstellen aber da sitzen dann viele spezialisten aus den raumfahrt agenturen dran um wirklich die beste und auch äh
zielführend die möglichkeit zu finden wo die mund station am besten platz.
Es wird ja kein es wird auch potenziell keine kein.
Kein projekt sein was eine raumfahrt nation im alleingang macht sondern es wird wie die internationale raumstation ein internationales unternehmen sein das heißt äh viele kluge köpfe sitzen da dran um auch das bestmögliche dann heraus.
Herauszufinden wo man das platziert für die pflanzen ich sag's mal so für die für die pflanzen ist es wichtig,
das licht bereitgestellt wird dass man auch einen gewissen zyklus hat dass man ein also das licht äh jetzt nicht permanent unter höchster intensität bereitgestellt wird das ist auch gewisse dunkle phasen gibt ähm
und damit kann man dann arbeiten ob das dann.
Künstlich in einer schatten zeit am äquator bereitgestellt wird oder ob es permanent bereitgestellt wird und man mit abschottung arbeitet.
Das ist dann muss man dann gegen rechnen was günstiger ist kann ich jetzt auf anhieb auch gar nicht sagen weil diese rechnungen werden im moment ja erst arbeitet.
Ja aber ist dann sozusagen also wenn man so sagen die technische kapsel dafür geschaffen hätte ich noch viele fragezeichen dranhängen man muss das ganze zeug da hinkriegen leute müssen da vor ort sein wenn es bauen und so weiter und schon.
Raumstation in vier kilometer entfernung zu bauen war schon schwierig genug und hat lange gedauert aber wäre und auch wenn ich jetzt so ein bisschen hinaus ist unser verständnis von pflanzen.
Wachstum und diesen bio kreisläufe schon.
Ausreichend um heute wenn die anderen rahmen parameter gesetzt werden sozusagen dort sofort anzufangen was anzubauen oder wäre das auch noch mit zu viel fragezeichen versehen.
Also man ist zumindest soweit dass man in der lage ist.
Pflanzen keimen zu lassen pflanzen zu kultivieren früchte zu ernten.
Und dann wird es spannend wie oft können wir das machen können wir da draußen kontinuierliche prozess entwickeln oder müssen wir diesen prozess irgendwann abbrechen und brauchen wir ich sag mal frischen nachschub an samen.
Weil die strahlung so stark ist weil das sozusagen und einfach weg mutiert.
Und da darf darüber gibt es keine gibt es noch keine erkenntnisse.
Ich würde ja auch sein dass da sozusagen so 'ne art mond stattfindet die sich dort eben unter diesen bedingungen besonders entwickeln.
Das ist eben der punkt dass natürlich auch pflanzen sich jetzt nicht nur an eine andere umgebung anpassen können also nicht nur die schäden die durch eine erhöhte strahlung,
passieren ist man kann es natürlich auch die frage stellen schützen wir unsere biologischen systeme auf der mond oberfläche durch einen entsprechenden strahlung schutz das heißt geht wieder so unter die ähm unter die mond oberfläche und ähm
schauen dass wir auf einem akzeptablen äh dass wir eine entsprechend akzeptablen strahlung dosis bekommen.
In so einem der krater die dort.
In so einem krater oder gerade jetzt eben auch der mond oberfläche selber wenn man da entsprechend etwas unter die fläche geht dann wirkt es auch absorbieren was die strahlung angeht.
Und nicht nur dass ich meine mangels eine atmosphäre schlagen ja auf dem mond auch noch regelmäßig meteoriten ein also ist ja auch nicht ganz ungefährlich da direkt auf der oberfläche rum.
Also ich sag mal so die glas sozusagen bei uns für zwei übersetzt auf die mond oberfläche wird wahrscheinlich nicht ganz so funktionieren,
und da ist natürlich auch die frage die pflanzen werden nicht direkt dem dem dem sonnenlicht ausgesetzt sondern das sonnenlicht wird gesammelt und den dann eben über entsprechende filter auch den pflanzen zugeführt.
Aber die pflanzen werden sich anpassen wenn sich anpassen an den an die reduzierte,
schwerkraft werden sich anpassen an die umgebung die um sie herum ist das können sie auch in der natur sehr gut beobachten dass sich äh pflanzen auch anpassen was haben sie für nachbarn,
und wenn sie den pflanzen das ist ja immer die große warnung monokulturen pflanzen monokultur landschaften sind anfälliger,
sie brauchen eigentlich eine gewisse diversität um auch ähm entsprechend resilient gegenüber krankheiten störungen auch zu sein aber wie viel ich sage mal bisschen flapsig gesprochen wie viel artenvielfalt wollen wir uns denn überhaupt gönnen,
auf der mond oberfläche da wird natürlich jeder biologe sagen wir brauchen eigentlich eine eine monokultur weil die verstehen wir am besten die haben am besten an eingehend sind.
Untersucht und diese langzeit erfahrung die man macht die langzeit erfahrung was die anpassung des organismus an die veränderten umgebung bedingungen angeht.
Die fehlen uns im moment noch die wird man deswegen hab ich vorher von baustein gesprochen die wird man auch bausteine artig dann auf der wohnfläche auch erst sammeln müssen ähm und wenn man sieht.
Dann auch gut voran das ist erfolgreich dann wird es auch zunehmend in den alltagsbewegung trieb in den herkömmlichen betrieb auch mit eingebaut werden.
Ja durchaus vorstellbar dass man dazu sagen unter solchen bedingungen auch wie man das eigentlich auf der erde ja auch macht meine wenn man heutzutage von pflanzen zucht,
spricht wissen ja wahrscheinlich auch nicht viele wie das so läuft so naja also neue weizensorten zu erfinden in anführungsstrichen.
Bestrahlt man die einfach mit radioaktive ausstrahlung klingt jetzt erstmal gefährlich aber bedeutet ja im prinzip nur
man bildet das was sonst normalerweise bei längeren zeitraum ohnehin stattfindet weil wir jetzt der strahlung trotz des schutzes der atmosphäre.
Permanent ausgesetzt sind über einen sehr kurzen einen sehr kurzen zeitraum wenn man das quasi auf den pflanzen material an dann setzt man die aus und guckt was ist denn jetzt haben sie irgendwelche vorteile oder nicht und wenn irgendwas ein vorteil vermeintlich hat
dann wird das eben in die nächste generation genommen weil es diesen prozess dann auf den mond sich weiterdenkt könnte man halt so super mond ketchup erzeugen der halt einfach ganz andere qualitäten hat nicht nur
besser angepasst ist an die strahlung situation sondern vielleicht noch ganz andere qualitäten entfaltet die wir hier gar nicht wissen weil dir was was ich
pflanzlicher zu viel gravitation hat oder so.
Das ist richtig nur muss man auch bedenken immer wenn sich auch ein organismus verändert dann wird sich auch seine frucht verändern und dann werden sehr schnell auch ähm
ernährungswissenschaftler fragen ja ist es dann noch ein passendes nahrungsmittel für den menschen oder entsteht da auch etwas was für den menschen schädlich sein könnte und das muss dann wiederum ausgeschlossen werden da wird auch noch sehr viel sehr viel forschung notwendig sein
weil wir im moment ja noch gar nicht wissen.
Inwiefern hat sich dann der biologische system also die tomate oder die mikro alge inwiefern hat die sich dann verändert und inwiefern sind plötzlich plötzlich die zusammensetzung anders.
Neues berufsbild mond vor costa.
Ja da steckt richtig viel futter.
Der ernährungswissenschaftler dazu.
Weißt du lustig jetzt bleiben wir nochmal kurz auf diesen fiction treppe können gleich wieder in die realität zurückkehren aber ist ja sozusagen jetzt mal das so richtung maß weiterdenkt dann haben wir jetzt schon ein paar mal angesprochen habe ja nicht nur das problem so wie jetzt
wieder hollywood referenz im film zu machen.
Dass jemand sozusagen mit diesen experimenten überhaupt erstmal überleben muss um eine chance zu haben zurück zu kommen sondern man muss ja überhaupt erstmal.
Hinkommen maß mission sind irgendwie
eine heiße diskussion derzeit die aber ich lasse den eindruck habe die wird so geführt und missachtung so viele realitäten also es gibt ja viele,
mehr oder weniger berühmte menschen die sagen ja zwanzig jahre noch und so weiter dann haben wir irgendwie die richtige rakete gebaut nur es liegt halt nicht nur an der rakete sah so eine mission hat viele aspekte unter anderem auch psychologische,
aspekte ich hatte ja auch schon mal ein gespräch,
über diesen psychologischen aspekt in der maß fünf hundert vision.
Das war siebenundzwanzig da bin ich nach holland gefahren habe ich mit der.
Jennifer rohr an unterhalten darüber wie das so abgelaufen ist also diese psychologische aspekt und jetzt haben wir noch diesen versorgungs- und klima und eben auch vielleicht psychologischen.
Was esse ich denn eigentlich das ist glaube ich noch sehr viel mehr science-fiction,
derzeit als es eigentlich in der öffentlichen diskussion so wahrgenommen wird oder.
Also jetzt äh hinsichtlich was man ist oder.
Also hinsichtlich von allen komplexität täten die sozusagen da dranhängen.
Aber speziell auch allein dieses versorgungs- problem weil man müsste glaube ich irgendwie sowas wie hundertvierzig tonnen zeug mitnehmen und wo sind wir jetzt gerade bei den raketen also so ein paar tonnen kriegen wir schon irgendwie hoch auf fünfhundertvierzig tonnen nur wirklich weiter.
Ja also wenn man alleine ein lebenshaltung system in der form wie wir's bauen wollen
also für die maß mission wie es jetzt auf der ist dann wiegt allein des lebens haltungssystem zwölf tonnen zwölf bis dreizehn tonnen.
Je nachdem was man dann für technologien benutzt vielleicht findet noch die ein oder andere biologische komponente mit einzug und durch die einsparung von nachschub masse kommt man vielleicht auf eine systematische nachher von zehn tonnen.
Ich denke mal ganz wichtig ist äh wenn man über maß mission entspricht.
Ich halte das gar nicht für unrealistisch dass wir mitte zwanzig der zwanzig dreißiger jahre dorthin kommen das alles ist auch ein bisschen eine frage des politischen willens und wohin dann die finanziellen ressourcen
auch fließen und in welche entwicklung in welche technischen und technologischen entwicklungen wir dann eintreten ich halte es
im moment für sehr wichtig und gut auch dass man sich jetzt auf die mond oberfläche fokussiert dass auch mal eine ansage da ist weil das war so ein bisschen die.
Das problem vor fünf jahren ja gehen wir jetzt richtung mond oder gehen wir richtung maß oder bleiben wir irgendwie in so einem
gedanken auch hängen oder denken wir jetzt über eine nachfolge der internationalen raumstation in größeren maßstab nach es war alles so ein bisschen floating.
International ne also.
International und dann haben da kam natürlich das war auch so ein bisschen die zeit jetzt hat natürlich auch verfolgt was die chinesen alles machen,
was china alles im stand.
Ist da schon von der ein oder anderen mission überrascht worden dass es die chinesen so schnell jetzt auch aufholen die chinesen sind jetzt in der in der lage menschen im weltraum zu bringen und wieder zurück.
Was haben die europäer nicht die amerikaner im moment auch nicht.
Mission zurück seite des mondes.
Richtig und das sind natürlich schon auch jetzt ganz spannende entwicklungen und ich glaube so ein gewisser wettbewerbs gedanke ist jetzt hat jetzt wieder einzug gefunden und er ist auch wichtig.
Weil man aus diesem ja wo wollen wir eigentlich hin äh wir wissen noch gar nicht genau wo wir jetzt unsere schwerpunkte legen soll deswegen ist jetzt dieses klares statement richtung mond oberfläche auch sehr gut,
bündelt wieder ressourcen es bündelt wieder gerade wenn man ziele ausspricht dann wissen auf einmal wieder alle wo es hingehen soll
und im moment ist die zeit auch noch nicht so weit dass man sagt wir wollen zum maß mitte zwanzig dreißiger jahre wo wir ein gutes zeitfenster hätten aufgrund der konstellation zwischen erde und mars jawohl da wollen wir benannt die momente mission zumal auch wagen.
Wir haben noch ein bisschen zeit und darüber international auch auszutauschen und auch diesen gedanken heran reifen zu lassen ähm.
Aber die äh der knackpunkt ist und da haben sie auch voll und ganz recht es sind noch viele technische fragestellungen ungeklärt ein schlüssel aspekt
ist dabei nicht unbedingt die biologie sondern ein schlüssel aspekt ist die ist der strahlenschutz also wie gewährleistet ich auch über eine mission von wird wahrscheinlich dann etwa.
Circa sechshundert bis neunhundert tage dauern äh man rechnet so grob ein jahr hin halbes jahr dort bleiben ein jahr zurück ähm.
Dann werden wir so grob bei den neunhundert tagen.
Oder achthundert tagen dann muss ich sicherstellen dass die astronauten und astronauten die daran teilnehmen auch diese diese mission.
Gut überleben und der strahlenschutz ist im moment noch der eine ein flaschenhals bei der ganzen thematik.
Und ein weiterer natürlich flaschenhals wird auch sein mit wird die antriebstechnologie sein wagt man sich tatsächlich wieder richtung.
Richtung antriebstechnologien vor die im radioaktiven bereich eben auch liegen,
das ist eben noch sind alles offene fragen die auch beantwortet werden müssen und dafür braucht es aber geld dafür braucht es das klar ausgesprochene ziel jawohl da wollen wir hin.
Damit wir auch rechtfertigen können jawohl dafür müssen wir auch das geld dann auch ausgeben,
und dafür fehlt im moment noch das nochmal diese klare ansage für den mund haben wir sie jetzt da bin ich auch sehr froh drüber und deswegen können wir auch wirklich dann über solche dinge reden was muss man denn alles tun damit wir auch permanent.
Astronauten auf der mond oberfläche mit frischem salat mit frischen tomaten mit frischen erdbeeren auch versorgen können und was braucht es nochmal für technologische know-how.
Weil das ist auch etwas was wir auch lernen müssen dass das wissen um einen prozess heißt noch lange nicht dass wir ihnen auch
beherrschen dass wir das technische system dann nachher beherrschen also so eine salat maschine mal ein bisschen bildlich gesprochen so ein großer kasten indem vielleicht salat salate mehrere generationen so langsam heran heranwachsen.
Das ist ja im prinzip auch eine pfiffige idee und wir wissen theoretisch
aber der teufel steckt immer im detail wenn das tatsächlich machen müssen wo sind die kleinen aber kritischen probleme die wir lösen müssen auf die wir eine antwort finden müssen und die können idealerweise dann vor ort auch getestet werden.
Und dann auch gelöst werden und dann sind wir wieder bei der bei dem ausgangspunkt wo stehen wir gerade mit
pflanzen im weltraum gerade bei der langzeit kultivierung da fehlt das know-how des biologische know-how des
kurzzeit kultivierung know-how das ist im wesentlichen ausreichend vorhanden aber man muss jetzt eben dann in die langzeit in die langzeit kultivierung gehen.
Warum ich hab's eigentlich keine pilze im weltall also ist immer so gibt's schon ja.
Ja das sind aber sporen also das tragen auch wir menschen automatisch in jede umgebung rein also diese art von pilzen gibt es schon aber sie machen wahrscheinlich ihr champignons.
Ja oder generell also ich glaube die wenigsten leute machen sich klar dass pilze ja sozusagen nicht pflanzen sind so das
auch irgendwas und erkenntnisse mich mal komplett vom kopf geschlagen hat so ja wir haben die tiere und wir haben pflanzen und wir haben pilze und auch wenn die irgendwie im gleichen gemüse regal liegen ist es ja einfach so ein organismus der uns immer wieder überrascht ich glaube der.
Größte zusammenhängende organismus auf diesem planeten der überhaupt schon mal gefunden wurde ist
pilze umso kilometer weit oder so einem wald boden erstreckt sich eine einzige der pflanze hält jetzt fast gesagt also ein einziges ziel
die wie oft ganz andere art und weise auch nochmal ein ja ein teil des gesamten organismus erde darstellen wo ich mir vorstellen könnte so naja okay alles was wir vielleicht
pflanzen nicht hinbekommt vielleicht sind pilze hier irgendwie eine lösung und pilze.
Wir könnten auch eine lösung sein man muss natürlich dieses ziel auch kontrollieren dass es eben nicht unkontrolliert auch
oder auch vor allem wir sind ja vor allem an den letztlich an der frucht in anführungszeichen interessiert als wenn der champignon wir sind am champignon interessiert und nicht am myzel selbst das myzel stellt aber sicher dass eben diese champignons hat auch wachsen können und wenn dieser prozess ordentlich kontrolliert werden kann
dann spricht auch gar nichts dagegen dies das einzusetzen wichtig ist aber auch die bereitstellung der umgebung für das myzel.
Bedeutet ja.
Also die bereitstellung einige umgebung wo das wo das modell dann auch wachsen kann mit welchem mit welchen stoffen muss sich dieses mitzählen auch versorgen.
Und habe ich diese stoffe im rahmen meiner gesamt bilanz.
Mensch im weltraum habe ich denn diese stoffe auch vorhanden oder muss ich diese stoffe permanent zu führen wenn ich am am ende des tages eben nährstoffe zu führen muss als ich nachher als andere in der hand halte dann ist das system nicht mehr relevant
also dann ist es auch nicht mehr rechtfertig war warum ich dieses system einsetzen sollte da wird's noch ähm das denke ich wird auch eine spannende fragestellung sein.
Deswegen grundsätzlich pilze im weltraum auch insekten im weltraum könnten auch eine rolle spielen.
Weißt du zum schluss haben wir denn eigentlich aus dieser ganzen pflanzen forschung im all auch dinge.
Sozusagen.
Gelernt die rück übertragbar sind also sehr schon mit der medizin ja also das ist so ein ein ein zweck medizinische forschung klar weil wir brauchen das für unsere astronauten aber vor allem lernen wir ja viel für die medizin.
Auf der erde steht es auch im mittelpunkt.
Hier quasi etwas auch im all zu lernen was wir dann wiederum auf der erde sinnvoll zum einsatz bringen können.
Also eher wichtig sind die grundlagen experimente die man für die weltraum anwendungen tätigt dass man diese grundlagen experimente auch für.
Für erde anwendungen nutzen kann ich denke da insbesondere darum wenn es um effizienz geht,
und auf engem möglich auf möglichst engem raum ein möglichst hohen möglichst hohe ernte auch zu erzeugen wir haben im weltraum immer den anspruch,
dass wir möglichst mit möglichst wenig energie aufwand.
Mit wirklichst leichtem mit möglichst leichter macht masse arbeiten möglichst klein auch arbeiten den bestmöglichen benefit haben und das ist jetzt wiederum übertragen auf die erde anwendung wirtschaftlich.
Das heißt wenn man es schafft in einer isolierten umgebung in einer effizienten form,
pflanzen zum wachsen zu bringen und auch früchte zu ernten dann ist es etwas was auch für verarsche umgebungen auf der erde eingesetzt werden kann wenn man mal in richtung wüsten denkt oder in richtung oder auch katastrophen gebiete,
in katastrophen gebieten wenn ein ernteausfälle ist gibt es möglichkeiten dass man kurzfristig dort ähm installationen bereit.
In denen dann in einer salat maschine oder auch in einem foto biomarkt,
verschiedene mechanismen kultiviert werden schnell kultiviert werden und zumindest ein kleiner teil an an nahrung auch produziert werden kann und das ist.
Und das ist denke ich ein ein wichtiger aspekt den man daraus ableiten kann andere aspekt ist was sich so aus der aus der weltraum forschung nach und nach so durch die fundiert hat in die gesellschaft ist das ding.
Also dieses ich nutze unterschiedliche umgebungen ich nutze nur zur unterschiedliche umgebungen um pflanzen zu kultivieren also nicht jemand klassischerweise nur das feld sondern schau mir das auch ganz genau an.
Dass diese bedingungen die eine pflanze braucht um zu wachsen ich auf vielfältiger art und weise vorfinden kann gerade diese erkenntnisse die man dann auch bei der grundlagenforschung für die raumfahrt anwendungen macht dass man die da auch übertragen kann auf das formen
nämlich auf kleinsten raum möglichst viel anzug anzupflanzen möglichst viel
wachsen zu lassen und auch eine höchste ernte auch zu haben und gerade wenn man heute durch die städte geht oder durch größere städte geht man hat entweder an
höheren gebäuden hat man manchmal begründete fassaden also auch fassaden wo man,
früchte ernten kann aber man hat auch klassischerweise solche hochbett e oder klein auf engstem raum stadtgarten wo man auch versucht ähm.
Ja sozusagen gewisses know how dann anzuwenden was man dort gefunden hat ich finde es im wesentlichen auch ähm.
Sehr sehr spannend weil das zeigt diesen spinn online auf spin-off gedanken diesen was lernen wir was lernen wir aus der kultivierung von pflanzen.
Sowohl auch hier auf der erde wenn man hier schaut wie auch vorher wurde schon erwähnt von ihnen wie auch.
Bestimmte pflanzen einfach getrennt werden oder wie beispielsweise sich weizen auch verändert hat wie hoch effizient auch unsere landwirtschaft heute funktioniert
einfach sieht ein bauer hat früher bis vor sechzig jahren noch fünfzehn leute versorgt heute versorgt er hundertfünfzig personen so mal ganz grob formulieren damit man weiß in welche größenordnung wir uns heute bewegen
und dieses dieses diese diese effizienz gedanke der steckt natürlich in her rennt in dem,
in der weltraum anwendung auch äh auch drinne und.
Die anforderungen wird schon sein weil sonst werden biologische systeme nie konkurrenzfähig sind nominieren
es muss möglichst klein sein möglichst leicht und möglichst wenig energie verbrauchen und möglichst möglichst geringen wartung bedarf sein haben.
Und wenn diese kriterien erfüllt werden oder bis zu einem gewissen grad erfüllt werden dann sind sie konkurrenzfähig zu unseren klassischen technischen systemen von daher sehe ich da auch,
aufgrund der erfahrungen und erkenntnisse die wir heute haben ähm sehe ich da eigentlich schon große sich da ein großes potenzial
dass das auch gelingt wenn ich jetzt gerade das ganze nochmal auf die mikro alpen richte.
Auch in unserer forschungsgruppe eingehende untersuchungen system untersuchung gemacht.
Ab wie viel jahren ab welcher mission staumauer lohnt sich denn so ein foto bio reaktor für die kultivierung von mikro algen und dann kommen wir so in den bereich ein bis zwei jahre das heißt,
jede mission die kürzer dauert brauchen wir den foto bio rakka eigentlich nicht aber wenn
längere mission dauern haben dann stellt sich auch im gesamt system gewicht nachher ein vorteil ein und das ist äh auch nachher gut für die argumentation gegenüber den raumfahrtagentur warum so ein biologische system auch zielführend.
Und gleichzeitig muss man dann auch immer den parameter nochmal identifizieren möchte ich zielführend
eher die nahrungsbrei bereitstellung im fokus haben oder möchte ich ziel vor und die luft regeneration im fokus haben und da ist
nahrungsbrei bereitstellung eher limitierenden ich kann mich jetzt nicht nur von tomaten oder nur von mikro algen ernähren dass es zu einseitig
ich kann ein teil meines nahrungs bedarf damit abdecken ich muss aber auch schauen wie ich den anderen teil den ich ihm nicht abdecken mit welchem ähm.
Vielleicht auch herkömmlichen bewährten methoden denke ich diesen teil dann ab also das bedeutet eben dann doch noch ein bisschen trocken nahrung und auch trockenfutter was dann äh bereitgestellt werden muss.
Und.
Das heißt dass es dann vielleicht sogar noch die größere verheißung dass man für raumstation solche.
Luftreinheit jungs und andere kreislauf systeme quasi organisch organisiert als jetzt
in anführungsstrichen nur diese nahrungs option.
Ganz genau also es wäre falsch ähm das biologische system nur für die nahrungsmittel bereitstellung zu sehen weil automatisch ich brauche ja kohlenstoffdioxid.
Und die pflanzen emittieren ja sauerstoff und das wäre ja nicht klug
das ganze nicht mit berücksichtigt mit nicht mit zu berücksichtigen das heißt man wenn es das ganze im rahmen eines experiments natürlich stattfindet.
Dann sollte man das jetzt nicht in seinem alltags betrieb darauf ist sich darauf verlassen dass das immer so funktioniert.
Wenn aber die erfahrung soweit ist dass man sagt jawohl das ist jetzt ein operieren das system das haben wir im griff mit dem können wir arbeiten und wir kennen unsere stoff umsätze dann ist auch der richtige zeitpunkt gegeben und das in den alltag
betrieb zu integrieren zu wissen wie viel co zwei wird dort auch regelmäßig absolviert und wieviel sauerstoff wird imitiert
und an diesem an diesem punkt müssen wir unbedingt herankommen gerade auch wenn man dann auf der mond oberfläche wenn wir über die oberfläche nachdenken und äh da diese ganze erkenntnis die man daraus auch ähm
auch hat die wird uns auch hier auf dem planeten erde zugute kommen die wird uns zugute kommen weil wir
pflanzen händeln können weil wir
weil wir kennen lernen wie schnell können wir auch pflanzen kultivieren wie schnell können wir ernten schaffen wir das während des früher in vier wochen ähm machbar war schaffen wir das inzwischen in drei wochen und das kann natürlich dann auch sehr interessant sein für diverse anwendungen
auf der erde wenn wir auch dann zum beispiel,
in richtung herrscher umgebungen denken wüsten oder auch vielleicht die antarktis wo auch immer der mensch hin möchte hier auf dem planeten.
Ja ich äh beende das jetzt aber hier mal und bedanke mich erstmal ausführlich für die ausführung.
Zu pflanzen im weltall und ist ja noch ein bisschen mehr als das ist so ein bisschen auch so die suche nach unserem biologischen equilibrium im weltall sozusagen und auch vielleicht
technik auch anders zu sehen mit der wir künftig raumfahrt missionen vorantreiben.
Ich denke mal es geht im kern auch um um sowas ganz ganz originären wir wollen ein stück erde mit in den weltraum nehmen wir wollen.
Wir haben den anspruch zu verstehen wie unsere umwelt funktioniert wie unsere umgebung funktioniert wir möchten gerne ein teil von unserer erde wirklichkeit werden lassen an einer anderen stelle als auf der erde und deswegen ist auch pflanzen biologie und auch äh weltraum biologie
so spannend.
So sieht's aus ich sag vielen dank und auch vielen dank für's zuhören hier warum zahlt das war's für heute und bald geht's wieder weiter wie es hier immer weitergeht und sag tschüss und bis bald.
Aux